my stability here but we'll get to that
later oh so alright so why I left Smosh
alright but I'm actually gonna tell you
I'm definitely I'm gonna tell you and
you you just you just wait no I'm
licking my lips like I saw a [ __ ]
stack of ribs alright so we got a little
bit of t-ball so like just some real a
[ __ ] yeah some real a [ __ ] yeah so um
okay so some people that you know some
people watch Smosh I know a lot of like
JK like David fans and stuff but there
was a it was a video that we put out we
filmed in December I want to say of 2017
yeah and watch people this is video we
were like thank you for watching Smosh
it's just like it's really cringey but I
had to like let them know like what the
video was okay so it was like that video
and in the video they lined up all of
the cast in the front and then they were
putting staff like the whole staff of
Smosh in the background and we kind of
were like in Christmas Carol formation
right yeah and so the cast was lined up
first and so we were sitting there for
about 20 minutes while they lined
everyone up and um I had this revelation
because I was sitting there and I was
surrounded by I want to say there was
about 11 or 12 people in the cast at the
time I was looking around and I was like
these are some good-looking talented
funny kids yeah and there's 12 of us and
we're not all gonna make it yeah like
that's just some real [ __ ] and I had to
step back for a second I was like it's
ambitious to think that even one of us
is gonna make it and be successful in
this field battling out with everyone in
Los Angeles and so I asked myself three
questions basically I was like do I have
the connections to make it out here in
LA do I have the drive to be the top of
the entertainment industry and you know
do I have the skill to do so um and and
like this was all happening in that
video like before the video was shot cuz
I was like deep in it because I was like
damn you know and I and I was like well
I've lived in LA for a year so I
definitely don't have the connections
I've been a gamer for like 10 years I've
just been coasting you know and this and
this opportunity fell on my lap I was
now here like going and get it I haven't
been
putting out content for years and you
know dreaming I'm having my name in
lights so I didn't have the drive and
then on top of that I haven't perfected
my comedy as a craft and I've never
tried to do so I find myself to be
entertaining but I'm not necessarily an
entertainer so for me to go across the
board and say no to all three of those
questions was really enlightening
because I was like I don't think that
this is gonna be my industry I don't
think that this is for me and you know
if I do become successful in it I'm not
gonna take that away from someone who is
fighting for it and has been fighting
and dreaming for this for their whole
life well you're a really nice person I
don't even think about it like that I'm
like listen I think all this opportunity
I'm gonna take this from some other
[ __ ]
guess what guess what you didn't jump on
his stupid [ __ ] I just knew that I
didn't it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't my
top priority and another thing about me
is you got to stick to your values and
my values tell me that I have to be the
best at what I'm doing I have to be
excellent it's very important for me to
be you know in the top 5% Japanese like
what are you doing I have to be actually
if I don't become excellent I have to
kill myself with a separate goodnesses
the sword to the stomach I mean that's
what it why is because like you don't I
mean some people I how do I explain it
like I'm very competitive
okay I'm very very competitive so I if
I'm in the top 45 percentile which is a
sustainable entertainment career you're
still successful you're still making
money you're still making moves it's not
I'm not happy with myself I have to do
better and to enter a field that I'm not
really in control of my success was kind
of scary to me and it just wasn't my jam
you know I wasn't about it so so after I
realized that that was in 2017 I started
trying to look for ways within the
company to build my resume because I
wanted to stay out in LA you know I
wanted to make it work and and I had
like a boss that was like oh yeah well I
can help you career path into marketing
well like weeks or months and I realized
that wasn't happening so I started
trying to create shows that I could put
on my resume
and and I and I made like - I made one
show that was like kind of funny
whatever and then I came out with this
court parody show that did insanely well
you know the channel went from getting
like 200,000 views per video to like
this series was getting 1 million like
constantly yeah people loved that [ __ ]
and so I was really excited about it and
I was like damn I can put this on my
resume I'm producing in show running and
so right before the company shut down I
was in the middle of getting this really
[ __ ] fantastic survivor for Survivor
survivor style game shows approved where
it was just all the cast mates and we
were gonna start voting each other off
over [ __ ] it was like drama it was games
it was it was funny it was so good it
got greenlit we were going through we
were starting to figure out where to put
product placement and stuff like that
this [ __ ] was happening and then the
company shut down like out of nowhere I
was a little nervous at first because my
resume was not where I wanted it to be I
thought that I had like another year
there and they told us we're not getting
paid we're not getting paid severance
we're not getting paid out for the next
two months and and on the Wednesday that
I was told this we were told we may not
have even been getting paid for Monday
and Tuesday that we had just worked
because the CFO had quit it was just out
of left field so like my brain went into
like panic mode it was like all right
what do we do I went onto this website
to like